from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between movie theater food at AMC and
Odeon movie theaters in the UK and the
US this is food Wars
[Music]
it might seem like Odin and AMC are
different chains however they're
actually owned by the same company so
let's compare popcorn are the UK Odeon
Cinema comes in four sizes as a kids
regular
medium and large classic popcorn at a US
AMC comes in three sizes small regular
large and of course if you want to get a
to-go option they have the
AMC Mega bag
boom that's three times the size of the
standard large that's why a large Salted
Popcorn in both countries to see whose
large is bigger so our largest little
popcorn is actually I think come to 204
grams which is about 30 grams more than
we were supposed to get
194 grams of popcorn Avatar haven't seen
it and for my own morbid curiosity so
I'm gonna weigh it in the bag I don't
know just subtract like two grams how
much could the bag weigh this
all right
620 grams drinks at a U.S AMC Theater
come in three sizes small 20 fluid
ounces regular 32 fluid ounces and a
large Avatar 44 fluid ounces now show
kingly our drinks in the UK are actually
just as big as the US ones for once
Cinemas I think are the only place in
the UK where you can get a drink of this
size the thought of getting one of these
from a fast food place in the UK is
absolutely unheard of let's measure out
the large in both countries to see if
we're getting as much as we've been
promised wow it's pretty close what was
it supposed to be 44 by my calculations
they've pretty much nailed bang on the
40 ounce line so you're maybe not
getting quite as much as you were
promised admittedly we did lose a little
bit in transit and also a little splash
just on the table there so maybe you
could round it up generously to like
4142 which honestly even if it's
slightly less new being promised I think
we can forgive them certainly we can't
fault James Cameron for this certainly
we can't blame the navi of Pandora we
also have ice drinks which are the
ICONic Tango ice blasts we have them in
three sizes they're regular a medium and
a large Tango ice blasts are amazing
they have a bit of a cult following in
the UK I think like Cinema goes over
here really really love these you can
get them usually in two flavors which
are red and blue I don't know exactly
what they're supposed to taste of it's
kind of just like Tangy food coloring
anyway they're not supposed to look like
this as you can probably tell these have
just been sat out under the studio
lights for a while here's what they're
supposed to look like you can also get
ice beverages at the usamc primarily in
the form of an AC and they come in three
sizes normally but not the AMC we went
to they only had regular it should be a
small 20 fluid ounce the regular Avatar
way of The Wider Navi colored drink here
is a 32 fluid ounce and of course the
large is a 44 fluid ounce I think that's
the exact same size as the soft drinks
we just had I would like to request I
don't know how hard this is going to be
if Yulie and the rest of the
post-production team can make it look
like I'm in the underwater Avatar
with like me just swimming with the navi
right we I'm in the movie how hard would
that be can make it 3D as well that's
pretty easy right do you have that done
by end of day Friday
when I'm swimming around with Jake suely
foreign here is everything you'll find
at the UK Odeon Cinema that you won't
find in an AMC here's everything at a US
AMC you won't find at an Odeon we'll
start with the classic which is popcorn
in the UK it comes in two flavors a
salted or sweet you can also ask them to
mix them together for you salt and sweet
excellent contrast you won't find butter
popcorn anywhere on the menu in the UK
the fact that you guys are putting
melted butter on popcorn extremely weird
to us stop doing that
in the U.S a popcorn obviously comes
plain or salted but we also have butter
popcorn and yes Harry we like to put
melted butter all over our popcorn two
things I want to know one it's almost
always referred to as butter flavored
topping presumably because they can't
legally call it butter or maybe there's
other junk in there and it isn't
officially butter in America there's
just some people who are so nuts about
the butter AMC now has something I don't
know if this is to go or you get this in
the theater where they give you no joke
this thing of butter on the side to take
into the theater with you because
there's so much butter flavor topping
drama in the U.S AMC was like here just
take this and go to go do it yourself
oh
look at that you see that you see that
oh yeah yeah I want you to watch it pay
attention now imagine I'm eating this in
the dark oh I lick my butter so much
in my house
this is like the messiest snack in the
world
I never get Butternut popcorn this is so
gross
yeah it doesn't actually taste that much
like butter it has like a buttery flavor
to it yeah it's definitely flavored
butter that's not melted butter you can
also get sweets as a topping on your
popcorn in the UK this comes in the form
of Cadbury's dairy milk buttons as
Smarties Kit Kats and Rolos speaking of
popcorn you can also get cheddar popcorn
which is I don't know if this is just
none of your theaters really popular in
the UK at all but it's popcorn and it's
tossed in like cheese dust and also
caramel corn which is popcorn you
guessed it encased and caramel
there's a range of hot food options at a
UK Odeon Cinema including the following
firstly we have the iconic Cinema Hot
Dog now obviously you guys have hot dogs
in America however it's an exclusive
because ours is a pork sausage while
yours I think is beef that looks real
sad oh no
oh hot dog yay that's pretty good sized
hot dog right
movie theater hot dogs for some reason
are really good who knows that movie
theaters and ball games that's where the
hot dogs the absolute best next up we
have two Pizza options at UK ode in
cinemas you can get a cheese pizza or a
pepperoni pizza I haven't even opened
them and I'm losing my mind because this
is how they've been packaged and
presented to us
what is that
um I'm slightly at a loss for words
I might be giving them too much credit
here I think maybe if this were fresh
out of the oven which obviously this is
not it actually might be okay but
there's a reason why pizza boxes exist
for example maybe look into that in
future I'm just imagining any Italian
viewers watching this and just crying
it's like a flatbread pizzas the MCA
went to did not currently have them
because I went there right when they
opened they weren't ready yet but you
can get also a four cheese a pepperoni
or a supreme flatbed Pizza you can also
get yourself curly fries now we're
talking curly fries right hmm
The Impossible nuggets
yes for some reason I picked the
marinara let's do it who doesn't want to
eat
fake deep fried meat
dip it in a red sauce in a pitch dark
theater
nope oh wow
those are really bad we have pretzel
bites at our AMC you can get them
unsalted with cheese salted with cheese
which I got
garlic parmesan with cheese everything
bagel with cheese and cinnamon sugar
with icing
they don't taste bad but I grew really
chewy
I'm gonna want those right out of the
oven or the microwave you can also get a
Bavarian Legend pretzel the theater we
went to did not have them at the time
I'm filming this at a UK Odeon you can
get triple dip nachos which are tortilla
chips which come with guacamole salsa
and I think a cheese sauce this is how
it came what we have is just a bag of
plain tortilla chips
and a box labeled dips we have the
cheese sauce we have some very vibrant
guacamole like someone Blended up Shrek
we have
some tomato salsa gelapanos
think this was onion and chive dip maybe
I feel like I have to try and assemble
these somehow I want to do it in a way
but hopefully you guys can uh
join me along for the ride because it
could be interesting I want to try and
get some like layerage going on there
if possible
oh God
oh no that's okay I thought that all
came out as one brick but there were
actually two pots in there thank God go
on
there you go
look at that queso
okay now we're gonna hit it with some
salsa
[Music]
personally
I think this has gone sensationally well
this is
this is nachos right here
some people might say Harry
do you want to heat these up
I'd say no doesn't need it perfect the
way they are
man look at the color on this
Cinema no my mum used to like the nachos
she's not dead she I haven't been to the
cinema with her in a while laughs
yeah
they don't look terrible right
absolutely disgraceful I don't know
what's going on that island of yours but
your nachos thumbs down I would say
pretty generous with the chips not bad
right these are UK level nachos right
here I don't know who
is like oh yeah perfect this is exactly
what I think nachos are do they make a
mistake if I look at this right they
gave us a thing of marinara sauce I'm
assuming this marinara is supposed to be
salsa can you imagine because you just
get this and go to theater in the dark
and you're watching a movie oh man man
this salsa sure isn't very chunky oh
well man I cannot wait to eat these
nachos oh I'm so worried about the Tree
of Life Avatar too
oh
look what the hell it's so bad it's like
oddly alluring does that make sense
it's terrible I'm sorry I'm gonna do
everyone a favor and throw this out
yuck then we're on to the sides we have
a couple of side options in the UK that
you won't find in the US unfortunately
one of them we couldn't find today which
are crisper fries which are kind of like
very thin slices of potato which are
fried however we could get our hands on
these chicken strips it was actually
pretty good technically also included on
the sides menu are the dips so that
includes basically everything that you
would normally find on the nachos
including the side of jalapenos the
salsa dip the cheese the guacamole and
this cream cheese garlic and herb dip we
have one pre-packaged popcorn option if
you don't fancy the fresh stuff which is
this
buttercus toffee popcorn I think this is
kind of more similar to what you guys
might expect from like caramel corn in
the U.S it's basically popcorn but with
an actual coating of this kind of like
sugary syrupy stuff now the AMC has a
bunch of snack options that you won't
find in the UK starting with these known
as lifestyle snacks I'm assuming they're
meant to be a little bit healthier
starting all the way down here you have
the Planters sweet and salty trail mix
grass-fed beef jerky courtesy of country
Archer I don't know about this Rhythm
organic white cheddar cauliflower bites
no thanks
home free chocolate chip cookies we got
only three grams of sugar for the smart
and sweet watermelon bites mango sweet
and tangy super snacks dried mangoes and
skinny dipped dark chocolate almonds in
addition to the popcorn we also have
some sweets and chocolates which I will
go through now wine gums do you guys
have wine gums in the U.S I really like
these they're a bit of an old person
sweet I still don't know exactly why
they're called wine gums because I don't
think they have wine in them on top of
the gummies themselves they will have
like the name of a wine kind of stamped
on and they're different colors the
flavors change according to the color
red ones always the best of course a
couple of Cadbury dairy milk options we
have some Cadbury caramel dairy milk
nibbles dairy milk giant buttons Galaxy
minstrels so in the UK we have dairy
milk which is owned by Cadbury and then
the Mars Corporation has their own van
of milk chocolate which is called Galaxy
and this is basically Galaxy chocolate
with a hard shell on the outside these
honestly are really good Cadbury 12
bites it's Cadbury dairy milk chocolate
and it's kind of got this weird like
swirled texture on the inside so it
lends itself to being quite like a flaky
and almost like melt in your mouth
chocolate bar they're pretty good Arrow
peppermint bubbles it's got this weird
like aerated texture in the middle which
is designed basically to melt in your
mouth when you eat it milky bar buttons
I loved milky bar as a kit it's
basically white chocolate which I used
to love when I was younger I think as my
palette has kind of evolved as I've
gotten older I don't really tolerate
white chocolate like I used to but these
are great a bit of a Nostalgia factor
and the last one we found today was
maltesers I love a malteser I still
don't fully understand what they are to
be honest what is the middle base not
honeycomb but it's got like a crunchy
almost honeycomb texture now it's not a
pre-packaged option but it is a sweet
option we have pick and mix cups in the
UK pick and mix is like a really iconic
British thing I think it's basically
this notion of you go into a sweet shop
or in this case a cinema and they'll
have lots of different pots or tubs of
individual candies and you can go in
with a scoop scoop a few put them in and
create your own mixture of them so if
there's one particular one that you love
you can just have a cup full of that or
you can go for some variety mix it up a
little bit like we've done today the
issue is when you're layering it
you end up just going one layer of thing
at a time I haven't assembled this very
well couldn't get everything just
grabbed a bunch of stuff that they'll
look pretty good
also I think some Classics here Milk
Duds Junior Mints The Big Box
mini Snickers hey
Skittles my teeth are already starting
to hurt Butterfingers unwramped Minis
and
Sour Patch Kids and also Airhead
extremes this of course it's just the
tip of the iceberg you can get so so
many candies at AMC and this many
you can also get a Ben Jerry's milkshake
what they do is they let you choose
three scoops of ice cream of your
choosing and then pretty much just blend
them together to create a milkshake also
in the US we have ice cream you can't
get in the UK and get yourself a dibs
crunch a Haagen-Dazs bar Almond and
Nestle Toll House ice cream sandwich and
a Nestle's drumstick the other soft
drink exclusives are actually aimed more
at children we have some fruit shoots to
come either as this one which is Apple
and blackcurrant or as Orange it's just
kind of like a bottle of squash and for
the Americans who might not know what
squash is uh does cordial help at all
you get like a concentrated juice and
then dilute it with water to produce
basically this the main event as far as
I'm concerned when it comes to drinks
are these ones which are the alcoholic
options you can get alcohol at UK
Cinemas we got a few of the things on
offer today and these include this
recorder link strawberry and lime cider
we have a bottle of Heineken beer we
have some wine options we've got a
little bottle of red hair it's really
cute it's literally just like they've
taken a full-size bottle of red and just
squished it and scaled it down you can
also get white wine and I think rose
wine as well or if you're in a
celebratory mood
and get a little bottle of Prosecco then
we have some pre-mixed cocktail options
today we got a classic GNT and
a Jack and Coke what about the beverages
in the Eos we have so so many beverages
starting with the coke freestyle the
freestyle machine you've seen it before
it has all of these flavors
I wasn't getting one of each you can
also get a Gold Peak unsweetened iced
tea which they did not have a Gold Peak
sweet tea which they also did not have
and minimated orange juice and minimated
apple juice
chocolate milk
Dasani water Smart Water
and a Costa Coffee I also didn't have
that
I can really go some coffee I've been
told that it is interesting that we can
get close to coffee here it is actually
a British coffee chain but it was bought
by Coca-Cola in 2019 for almost 4
billion pounds and has now begun
expanding into the U.S
a large Salted Popcorn of the UK Odeon
contains the following
863 calories
48.37 grams of fat of which 37.84 grams
of saturated
92.18 grams of carbs of which 5.94 grams
of sugars and an unknown amount of
sodium unfortunately the website didn't
have the sodium information I did reach
out via the live chat function and the
guy said they didn't know what had gone
on he was going to look into it for me
but I did not hear back a regular plain
popcorn popped in canola oil is 550
calories 24 grams of fat 2 grams of
saturated fat 74 carbs 1 380 milligrams
of sodium the same size popcorn but this
time cooked in coconut oil
540 calories 24 grams of fat 17 grams of
saturated fat 74 grams of carbs and 1
380 milligrams of sodium now there are
no stats for the butter flavor tapping
which is a bit concerning but if you add
butter and salt to pretzel bites it adds
100 calories and 12 grams of fat 7 grams
of saturated fat 300 milligrams of
sodium
adding that same amount of butter to
this large Avatar way of the water
popcorn which is cooked in canola oil
you get 970 calories 51 grams of fat 10
grams of saturated fat popcorn in my
throat 117 carbs of which one gram of
sugars and 2 450 milligrams of sodium
same exact size of popcorn but this time
cooked in coconut oil and the butter
topping from before that's 960 calories
50 grams of total fat 35 grams of
saturated fat 117 carbs of which one
gram of that is sugars and the sodium
2450 milligrams people of the internet
canola oil has slightly more calories
but way less saturated fat huzzah a
large sweet popcorn in the UK contains
the following
1790 calories
73.08 grams of fats of which 55 grams
are saturated 253 grams of carbs of
which 8 4.04 grams of sugars and again
an unknown amount of sodium
gotta watch out for the caramel corn
Yulie this caramel corn in this size
bucket
1620 calories 64 grams of fat 21 of
those are saturated fat 510 grams of
carbs and of that 404 of those grams of
sugar
3190 milligrams of sodium now the large
cheddar corn seen here 1 620 calories a
144 total grams of fat 21 of those are
saturated 68 grams of carbs and 2
470 milligrams of sodium
what about the most colorific thing on
the UK menu well that would be a large
sweet popcorn
with the topping option a Dairy Milk
giant buttons this combination would
come to a total of 2004 calories 85.08
grams of fat 62.2 grams of saturated fat
275.8 grams of carbs of which
106.44 grams are sugars that is just
over 100 of your daily calories 109 of
your daily fat 311 of your daily
saturates and 212 of your daily sugar
jeez in the US our AMC menus vary I did
find a PDF that a bunch of stuff listed
on here I don't know how common it is at
AMC's but it is the Bavarian Legend
pretzel
with the cheese cup and mustard that
pretzel and mustard and cheese total is
1920 calories one thing I wanted to
point out is that
7600 milligrams of sodium that is
330.4 of your daily sodium intake hey
don't eat that pretzel
everybody
are you kidding me are you kidding me
okay okay Julie's gonna try and land one
another she chips a tooth okay she's
gonna have to pay for it where'd he go
bro